we demand baseball as well we demand it
know if we're gonna get it
my buddy from uh espn who had a nice
scoop yesterday carl ravitch joining me
back here on the show how you been carl
i'm good rents if i and i know now if i
need a good attorney
rich eisen is the guy i'm calling hey
carl man that lockout i
i i got a two-lane law
sports degree conferred upon me by gabe
feldman unfortunately he did not sign it
and i did not notice that until after i
left his presence so
i think i still have an unsigned degree
somewhere but that lockout man
i learned a lot about labor law and
unfortunately it seems to be
uh i'm putting it into practice talking
about baseball too much lately carl
well every time and i you know again i i
tend to look at what's going on
currently differently than i would a
labor negotiation and yet this is
dissolved into a labor negotiation as
opposed to a way
to get your butts back on the baseball
field to have the owners
uh have baseball being played again it
has literally become
a cba conversation the cba doesn't
expire until 2021.
this should be solely about getting back
on the field during a pandemic
and everybody realizing we're going to
lose some money in all of it
we're still going to get paid a hell of
a lot of money but we're going to lose
money and as
owners we're going to have to pay money
and we're going to lose money
that seems to have been lost rich along
the way and that that is labor law
you got to remember as we romanticize
about uh the yankees and the mets and
the cardinals
and cubs and dodgers and angels there's
no romantics involved in the game at
this level this is a business it's about
what am i going to get
and how much am i going to pay and for
those who sit there and say
can't they just and why don't they just
and don't they understand
the simple answer is no it has nothing
to do with any of the things that we
would wish
it would have to do it so
how do we change that carl because we've
already
uh based on uh you know as john heyman
your
our colleague at mlb network pointed out
the new proposal
has already moved uh opening day from
july 4th to july 10th we've already lost
a week on that calendar
and i know nobody really wants to play
into november for many reasons whether
or if the regular influenza
season hits when covert 19 might spike
again that's the last thing you want to
do is be blowing into your hand
off the mound in november the third and
putting your hand on a baseball and
putting it into play so um
how do we change all this carl which get
rich by one side
recognizing that they have an incredible
opportunity while they're tying all this
back together with the 2021 cba
uh recognize that this is a unique
situation in our country's history
one of the sides has an opportunity to
say you know what
we do actually recognize what's going on
we do
understand that baseball would be
important for people as a diversion from
all that's going on
we get the idea they want to see us back
on the field and on their televisions
and on their ipads and phones and
whatever we understand that
so as a result we are really going to
bite the bullet on this one
and we're going to pay the players a pro
rated salary for
70 games or we're the players and we're
going to take a pro rated
80 salary for 70 games whatever it might
be
and and while we continuously try to
endear the public to our side
the best way to do that now is to say
you know what
we actually do want to listen to what
you folks are saying
and not just make this about how much we
get and how much we spend
but recognize there's a value in coming
back and
we will ingratiate you to if you if this
is important yet it seems to be
our side when it's time to negotiate a
new cba
and if one of these one of these sides
is
is
a boy enough to become a man in this
situation
we'll have a longer season if not we'll
play 48 games
what would be the problem with playing
48 games carl lay that one out for me
i know honestly rich i've always looked
at this as an opportunity i think that
however many games there are this is
just me
this is not speaking for anybody but me
i looked at this op
as an opportunity get back on the field
if you want devise a tournament
the concept of this being remotely
considered a season or anything that
would have to do with any record books
forget it not not part of the deal this
is a unique opportunity
go and devise some type of regular
season with a great tournament to get
a postseason i don't even care if you
call it a world series winner
call it something else but you had an
opportunity
to be back on the field before others
you had an opportunity to make this
unique and memorable
you had an opportunity to experiment and
yet you're mired in arguments you had in
1981 and 1994
uh it doesn't it doesn't resonate it
doesn't make a lot of sense to me and
it's a blown opportunity so i think the
48
because of the acrimony rich it feels
like
you've agreed to go on a date with
someone you know
you don't like and it's not going to go
any further you're entering into a 48
game season
with a whole heck of a lot of bitterness
not only in your own camps
but a bunch of fans who realize you two
can't get along
why would i invest in 48 games
when you've told me you're not even
invested in it you're so
caught up in your own fights so i i
think that's what the problem
with 48 is it's a resignation to an
agreement that was made in march
and more proof we couldn't figure out a
way to give you guys
you know 70 to 85 regular season games
we couldn't do it
so sorry here here you know what we
didn't have cheese or sauce on the pizza
but we got some bread enjoy the bread
enjoy the bread call ravitch and i guess
just you know continue on the whole
dating analogy
we need somebody to say it's not you
it's me and really mean it
and come to the table right you know
just and really mean it's not you it's
me um
who's that person going to be the
commissioner is it going to be it's tony
clark
is it boris i'm serious like like like
like let let's hash let's
brass tacks it hash it all out about
what really does need to happen
and who's got to be the one to move here
carl
not to put you in too much of a spot no
that's okay
if i were if i were to handicap that and
i'm not sure which
any one of those three you just
mentioned would do it
because i think the commissioner answers
to owners
and when you have to answer to somebody
and you're not making the call
similar with the union you know you're
answering to all the players
um if i were to handicap it and somebody
had to
just given where we're at i would think
it would be the commissioner be only
because
he has historically and since we've had
labor peace been in the middle of it all
he is i think he prefers
a deal i think he prefers a deal that
benefits the owners
but i think in the end he prefers a deal
versus this 48 game idea
i'm not sure that scott does and again
if they were on the other end of this
call they'd say that's bull and of
course we prefer a deal
but it's going to be fair for the
players and i think the commissioner
is more in a position to make a deal
and say guys here's here's here's the
deal
i'm ready to do this i think it's
important
we're losing four billion dollars
whatever it might be
um you know and in other years this is a
this is a multi multi multi billion
dollar industry
will make it back and i don't know that
anybody would blame the side that does
that
in the next real cba negotiation
to side with them and say look they took
one for the team
you're not getting any hometown
discounts the next time
i would think if i were handicapping it
it would be
rob but i'm not not holding out hope
that anybody's doing it well i heard the
math that you used before
as a an example um
and you said 80 of a pro-rated salary so
again
so you prorate for 70 games and then you
take 20
off that and that's what the players
would make but that's still 20
less than the hundred percent that they
say that they negotiated in march
and the that's my concern here carl uh
that clearly that had there been a
collective bargaining agreement already
signed
like the nfl was fortunate to have maybe
this acrimony wouldn't be happening but
we are here my concern is that if the
players keep saying hey
march is march and we don't care what's
happening now
because it's march and you said yes in
march and we said yes in march and it
doesn't matter when
we're sticking with march that if the
owners begin to think that they're
negotiating against themselves they'll
walk
that that's my concern if they think
that they're they don't have a partner
across the way that's really negotiating
it's possible i don't think that the
commissioner would allow that because i
don't think
having been through what he's been
through in 94
um you know in the right-hand man is
that he
on his watch would want the game to stop
i don't think he's
i don't think he's going to allow it i
think there's going to be baseball
to your point about the march agreement
and i do believe that this was
subsequently discussed amongst the
players
and tony um i'm not certain that they
recognized the march agreement does
stipulate
and most labor lawyers would tell you
that march agreement
does allow for a negotiation if the
games are going to be played
in front of empty stance so while there
was a
100 percent of a pro-rated salary
there is a cause in there which if you
read it and most labor lawyers will tell
you
uh it says the commissioner has the
right
to renegotiate with the players on uh
on a potential concession on salary if
we're playing
in front of empty stands we know we're
doing that especially to start
so i think that your your argument um
would probably again i'm not a labor
lawyer i know you are
i think we would lose in court because
there is that stipulation
in front of nobody the 100 percent
prorated doesn't really stand we have
the right to go back
and talk about concessions on that were
you on sportscenter yet when there was
that strike
when there was a were you all right yeah
i was chasing owners around streets in
new york and toronto
paul beaston tucking in a lot of
buildings bud ceiling not wanting to
talk about anything
a guy named richard ravitch who is
representing one of the sides who
everyone thought was
associated or related to me which wasn't
the case
yeah none of it's ever fun and that's
why you know
those of us that are intimately involved
with this sport and not the nfl
like you are you know you're up all
night not necessarily
because the kbo is starting in an hour
you're up because
you're dealing with a group that just
doesn't seem to
get it especially in light of this i i
think people would accept
the fighting and the bickering and the
acrimony if this was a four or five year
deal
for the future cba this is literally
about getting back on the field
in 2020 and the lines have been so
blurred and the circles have become so
concentric
they can't see the the forest you know
through the trees
so um i guess
timeline it for me deal has to be done
by when
what when's the strike when's the stroke
at midnight here
uh well i i just you know it depends on
on which side you're talking to but i
think that the i think that the
agreement um or the commissioner saying
boys
we're going and it's 48 games and we're
done negotiating because
we don't feel you're negotiating we
wanted to play more games
albeit at a reduced rate on your salary
but we we would like to play more games
and if we can't agree
to that and you're stuck on 100 of your
salary
and they have the right to do that then
we're going to play 48 games
i think within the next 72 hours we
should have an answer to that
i really do huh and then what are the
odds that some uh
bold-faced name players who might have
an
uh an agent and scott boris say we're
not coming
because we're concerned about the health
then
you know um yeah and look i i think if
there are legitimate concerns about the
health i think that they're
going to be excused and get paid and get
service time
um i i have a i just look at some of the
parts of the proposals and again
when it is literally about the dollar i
understand
both sides of the argument but i think
with regards to health and safety
i think it's short-sighted to suggest
that any
organization would put their employees
baseball players at any any real
uh perceived risk i think every attempt
will be made to make sure
the risks are limited but that that is a
prerogative and
again because it's baseball nothing like
that would surprise me
nothing you know that's that's what
we've been conditioned to
in this game and i know you you know you
you of course
are familiar with the way it works it's
it's never peaceful
it's just not something that ever smooth
it's uh and i hope it doesn't happen
this way because
uh unlike 94 uh carl with you being on
the front lines of reporting this
you don't have the feel good addition to
the sports center to go back to and do
you don't have that feel good
you know the feel good we don't have
pool richardson on the court
we don't have sparky uh looking in the
mirror we don't have any of that
give me your favorite killborn story
carl give me give me give me your
favorite
killer story do you have one uh come on
uh well i told you i mean you know
probably three weeks into the kilborn
uh experience yes it went from
experiment to experience
but three weeks in our buddy steve
anderson who was in charge of sportsner
at that time
yes uh i knocked on the door i said
steve
uh i'm i don't get it i'm not feeling it
the still good thing i i don't get any
of this and to his great credit he said
carl please be patient you're doing
great you know you're riding a shotgun
with a guy who
uh we we believe is gonna develop and
and he did
and and i was wrong in my initial
judgment like
i don't get any of this stuff you know
the the uncle who is behind the uh
shed waiting to tie some boys ice skates
here are the penguins rangers highlights
what does that mean
what does that mean and then he starts
talking about shatner and then it was
kismet right then
and then you got it everything was cool
richardson
every basketball highlight had a poo
reference in it even when pooh
wasn't involved in the game oh
my god girl i mean oh
you're the best my word and then did he
call you sparky just from the beginning
like
did you walk in the door as a as a
newbie and call everyone sparky or he
or he he he had some humility when he
walked in the door
some he was a little bit humble when he
walked in the door
wow that that's a legitimate question
it washed off real quick um but yeah i
mean everybody
everybody became sparky that was and
then that sort of spread
through the newsroom i mean that was the
reference everybody used
to everybody i know when i when i
arrived in 96 people are calling me
spark and i'm like why am i being called
spark
because you refer to everyone as sparky
and you know we had
i had i had killer here uh on the latest
anniversary of espn i i lose track how
many years it's been it's
uh i saw i saw that it was beautiful i'm
glad to see
i i i saw that it came on for a full
hour and he made it
and he it was a feel feel-good and uh
and and he brought on we we made
martinis he made martinis even though i
think the
the ice wasn't his uh uh liking or
something
but he still he fought through it yeah
he fought through it he fought through
it
carl and he's
well you are too bless you for being in
the middle of all this and i hope we get
uh
some resolution man because um what an
opportunity this would be
and it would be something you know
take care of you and your family best to
you bud everybody be good
that's karl ravage everybody hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here